d'après l'article de jean marc morandini
reçoit un twittos a révélé deux cartes
du jeu de société burger quiz qui
sortira le 16 octobre de cartes dont une
voilà qui qui parle de moi et l'autre
qui parlent de rigueur
les chroniqueurs regardez le fameux
tweet en question et vous a fait une
petit un petit récap de cette histoire
regarder le tweet voilà donc cyril
hanouna kim jong-hun où les deux rappels
et kim jong-un capucine anarchy et kim
jong-un basséen corée du nord c'est un
dictateur ah oui oh ça va quoi quand
vous comparez à ça quand même
oui alors j'étais un petit à petit défi
quoique essien ou pardon de moi demain
la main et doit faire toutes les
missions qui s'alimentent d'accord
plutôt c'est un peu du bon ski c'est un
peu du bon ski mais j'aime bien j'aime
beaucoup les chéris j'aime beaucoup
alors il ya aussi l'enjeu teulat telle
avantage je ne t'ai pas l'air con j'aime
bien au delà témérité chroniqueur tpm
paix ou les deux ou vous avez un petit
récap de cette histoire
regardez tout ce que vous en pensez
c'est parti on le savait entre l'équipe
de burger quiz et cyril hanouna ça n'a
pas toujours été la fête
on se souvient des déclarations hostiles
d'alain chabat en septembre dernier dans
le jdd
cyril hanouna dans burger quiz c'est non
je sais qu'il a envie mais je ne vois
pas ce que je pourrais faire avec lui
mais alors que les choses semblaient
s'être calmées entre les deux hommes les
équipes du jeu de tmc en remet une
couche avec la sortie du jeu de société
burger quiz où on peut retrouver un
questionnaire intitulé cyril hanouna kim
jong-un
ou les deux et les propositions de
réponses ne sont pas moins agressive
souffre du culte de la personnalité
humilie ses collaborateurs mais des
coups de pression par téléphone une
autre carte du jeu tacle même les
chroniqueurs de tpm p mais à quel jeu
joue alain chabat
j'aime bien la petite musique alors
alain chabat dont alors je vous le dis
c'est une vraie info c'est vraiment dans
le jeu puisque je me suis renseigné
auprès de la production est ce que vous
trouvez voilà ce que vous trouvez que ça
va trop loin ou est ce que ça vous fait
marrer
tu te la vérité vous pouvez tout dire
ici vous pouvez dire qu'ils ont fait
marié moi il ya des trucs qui m'ont fait
marrer injuste bien une info c'est ce
jeu a été écrit au mois de juin donc
c'est avant que vous commencez vous fêté
avec alain chabat s'y perdre et donc ça
a été validé par à l'équipe de jeu de
tf1 et ce qui est amusant c'est que a
priori la production je me suis
renseigné voulait enlever ces questions
pour pas en venir
visiblement c'est passé à céret du filet
alors le jeu était reçue pour ceux qui
ont précommandé il sent le cese d'accord
de la normale
voilà lolo est ce qu'on serait pas
d'accord pour dire que burger quiz et le
jeu le plus drôle de tous les temps à la
télé des rabais non non non le suicide
aura six mois je suis d'accord et oui
c'est le jeu c'est le jaune égale à 1
chabat est un génie seuls les abonnés
c'est du moins est-ce que à vous vous
n'avez pas alors c'est que moi je suis
un petit peu d'accord avec toi là dessus
c'est vrai que nous on est les premières
fracassé tous mon côté on dit carmine
fait rien mais oui ça dans danse avec
les stars tout ça je confirme on voit ça
ça ça me fait plutôt marrer
après c'est vrai qu'alain chômage et
parce qu'il est avec nous je crois qu'il
nous aime beaucoup en fait parce que il
ne parle que de moi dans ses interviews
le kaiser voilà il le cache bien qui
nous aime beaucoup il le cache bien mais
on a l'impression qu'ils ne l'avaient
toujours braille au tessin donc merci
alain chabat écoutez j'ai envoyé un sms
à carcanières croyant que c'était lui et
on m'a répondu ce n'est pas le jeu c'est
toujours pas son numéro alain si tu veut
m'appeler avec plaisir voilà on
discutera tous les deux voulaient
foutsou numéro sûrement oui je vais pas
pour la peine pour direct parce que
[Applaudissements]
sa gueule
ah ouais
à l'eau alors appelé à ce que alain est
un ami et il aimerait peut-être pas que
je balance son numéro donc je n'ai pas
le balancier vous ben ali élargi il ya
qu'à moi non non non je suis avec ton
parti j'aimerais pas comme le pas je le
fais pas d'accord bon ce droit elle est
moins d'état moins c'est son droit mais
c'est vrai qu'il reste avec moi en tout
cas alain si tu m'aimes
fais moi une vraie déclaration vient de
voir avec des fleurs à la maison voilà
on fera non mais c'est mais ne seront
non le tarn fait bâcher merci il faut
pas oui je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec ma fille là dessus ça m'a pas du
tout fait rire d'abord je trouve qu'il
est nul c'est un vieil aigri jamais mais
son jeu est un jeu nîmes
mais ça c'est mon point de vue et en
plus cela vous comparez un dictateur
nord-coréen avec ses presque de l'injure
publique
le courrier attaquer et vous gagnez
ainsi je vous le jure public dit je suis
là vers l'attaqué parce que je vais pas
rentrer vous auriez moi ce que je
pourrais tout va attaquer la corée du
sud comme non mais alors ça va moi si
j'étais lui franchement et je lui dis ça
on peut se parler qui m'appelle
gentiment où on va se parler tous les
deux mais qu'il arrête de parler de moi
par presse interposée c'est vrai que
parce que quand j'essaie de le joindre
il me répond jamais j'essaie d'avoir son
numéro il ya tout le monde ne lui
donnait pas
et en plus j'ai toujours été sympa avec
lui vous vous êtes trompé tim ce que
vous aimez bien là chabat et moi j'adore
alain c'est un pote depuis des décennies
et au delà de ça je trouve
personnellement que c'est un génie et
burger oui je sais les agents vous aviez
fait une émission vous êtes plutôt
burger quiz ou strike ah ben c'est
ariane pas photo il vous paraît c'est
vrai et moi et moi par où je préfère la
gaffe alain chabat je trouve qu'il a un
talent exceptionnel aussi la gare et
badji bon son voilà dans son registre
oui même après ce jeu ça fait partie de
la guéguerre médiatique moi j'ai connu
peut-être alain chabat et même s'il
n'est pas responsable peut-être deux
sets de 7-6 et sincères avec toi de lui
ouais en tout cas moi je trouve qu'on a
pas à se transformer gilles en police de
l'humour
voilà bah valider des vannes des
invalides et se serait fait pas des
vannes victor c'est pas une vie la
région l'avait fait le dire la vérité
mon avocat m'a appelé et il m'a dit est
ce que tu veux qu'on attaque un peu
importe je veux dit non on s'en fout
c'est vrai il a tracé mais ces parias
des chanteuses populaires qui viennent
sur un plateau on s'est souvent [ __ ]
de leur gueule parce que parce que les
gens populaires ont ce mode ne voit la
sentence à témoin de connectif comme
salaire on se fout de ta gueule
exactement tu devrais flatté mais je
suis fatigué bien celle où pouvait juste
j'aimerais bien voilà câlins on se voit
on se parle un jour tous les deux
tranquille parce que c'est vrai qu'on
voit là on a plein de potes on commet
plus dont le loup est sûr est que les
gens ne comprennent pas cette guéguerre
entre alain chabat on et j'ai pas là on
a toujours été cool avec we will et moi
j'aime beaucoup alain chabat jeu comme
laurent j'aime beaucoup l'émission
allait elle est sympa à regarder
c'est très bien mais par contre les
cartes sur les jeux c'est remettent une
couche ça sert à rien la carte avec
l'allusion au dictateur c'est stupide
c'est bête
il faut qu'ils fassent des vannes le
jour d'émission c'est très bien on est
là pour ça pour regarder des vannes
mais quand on voit les cartes là ça sert
à rien vendre un produit dérivé
ça va tu le fais si tu le fais pendant
l'émission parce que l'émission et bien
moi j'aime bien burger quiz c'est des
tauliers que ce soit serré l'anac soit
alain chabat c'est des gens qui nous
font real fabre mais bon la asus est
centraux l'exercice en trop et c'est
surtout le jeu de la provocation inutile
ce que dès le départ vous ne vous n'avez
jamais craché sur l'émission en direct
on peut dire ce qu'on veut voilà mais
c'est une manière de sa part 2 et fendre
et douvrin d'ouvriers la balle tout
simplement
c'est ce que je reproche probables dont
le principe est plutôt rigoler mais je
trouve ça pas très drôle trouve ça un
peu aigri un peu méchant hassine et pas
tellement drôle j'étais habitué à mieux
et là je ne passerai la très drôle quand
j'ai lu rieuse mans alors moi je prête à
shaba un immense talent et justement mon
début je me suis dit non c'est
impossible que celui enfin équipe parce
que c'est pas très drôle alors on va
voir ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs
voilà alain chabat burger louise attaque
ou encore choqué 43% pas choqué ça fait
bien sûr ils sont un peu comme nous
voilà c'est dans la vanne c'est comme
quand nous c'est comme si karine ferri
ou d'autres animateurs disait voilà
voilà avons les charrient alors que
c'est le principe de l'émission rio
c'est le principe de faire des vannes
après voilà tout le monde fait des
vannes après c'est juste principe d'être
drôle ou pas drôle mais aussi il nous
arrive de rater des vannes et en engrais
souverain